do you bring this trick out at parties
oh no it's a terrible party trick here
we go
three point one four one five nine two
six five three five eight nine seven
eight this is grant gusman he watched an
old video of mine about how we think
that there are two systems of thought
system two is the conscious slow
effortful system and system one is
subconscious fast and automatic
to explore how these systems work in his
own head grant decided to memorize a
hundred digits of pi
three four four six then he just kept
going he has now memorized twenty three
thousand digits of pie in preparation to
challenge the north american record five
four nine three zero three eight one
nine six that's two hundred
that's amazing
i have wanted to make a video about
experts for a long time
this is magnus carlson the five-time
world chess champion he's being shown
chessboards and asked to identify the
game in which they occurred uh this
looks an awful lot like
tal botwinic
[Music]
now i'm going to play through an opening
and
stop me when you recognize the game and
if you can tell me who was playing black
in this one
okay
i'm sure you've seen this opening before
okay it's going to be arnold
against
zabata
how can he do this it seems like
superhuman ability well decades ago
scientists wanted to know what makes
experts like chess masters special do
they have incredibly high iqs much
better spatial reasoning than average
bigger short-term memory spans well it
turns out that as a group chess masters
are not exceptional on any of these
measures
but one experiment showed how their
performance was vastly superior to
amateurs in 1973 william chase and
herbert simon recruited three chess
players a master an a player who's an
advanced amateur and a beginner
a chess board was set up with around 25
pieces positioned as they might be
during a game and each player was
allowed to look at the board for five
seconds
then they were asked to replicate the
setup from memory on a second board in
front of them
the players could take as many
five-second peaks as they needed to get
their board to match from just the first
look the master could recall the
positions of 16 pieces the a player
could recall eight and the beginner only
four
the master only needed half the number
of peaks as the a player to get their
board perfect
but then the researchers arranged the
board with pieces in random positions
that would never arise in a real game
and now the chess master performed no
better than the beginner
after the first look all players
regardless of rank could remember the
location of only three pieces the data
are clear chess experts don't have
better memory in general but they have
better memory specifically for chess
positions that could occur in a real
game the implication is what makes chess
masters special is that they have seen
lots and lots of chess games and over
that time their brains have learned
patterns so rather than seeing
individual pieces at individual
positions they see a smaller number of
recognizable configurations
this is called chunking what we have
stored in long-term memory allows us to
recognize complex stimuli as just one
thing for example you recognize this as
pi rather than a string of six unrelated
numbers or meaningless squiggles for
that matter
there's a wonderful sequence i like a
lot which is uh
30173
which to me means stephen curry number
30
173 games which is the record back in
2016. so 30173
at its core expertise is about
recognition
magnus carlson recognizes chess
positions the same way we recognize
faces
and recognition leads directly to
intuition if you see an angry face you
have a pretty good idea of what's going
to come next
chess masters recognize board positions
and instinctively know the best move
most of the time
i know what to do i don't have to
figure it out
to develop the long-term memory of an
expert takes a long time ten thousand
hours is the rule of thumb popularized
by malcolm gladwell but ten 000 hours of
practice by itself is not sufficient
there are four additional criteria that
must be met
and in areas where these criteria aren't
met it's impossible to become an expert
so the first one is many repeated
attempts with feedback
tennis players hit hundreds of four
hands in practice chess players play
thousands of games before their
grandmasters and physicists solve
thousands of physics problems
each one gets feedback the tennis player
sees whether each shot clears the net
and is in or out the chess player either
wins or loses the game and the physicist
gets the problem right or wrong
but some professionals don't get
repeated experience with the same sorts
of problems political scientist philip
tetlock picked 284 people who make their
living commenting or offering advice on
political and economic trends this
included journalists foreign policy
specialists economists and intelligence
analysts over two decades he peppered
them with questions like would george
bush be re-elected would apartheid in
south africa end peacefully would quebec
secede from canada and would the dot-com
bubble burst
in each case the pundits rated the
probability of several possible outcomes
and by the end of the study tetlock had
quantified 82
361 predictions
so how do they do
pretty terribly these experts most of
whom had postgraduate degrees performed
worse than if they had just assigned
equal probabilities to all the outcomes
in other words people who spend their
time and earn their living studying a
particular topic produce poorer
predictions than random chance even in
the areas they knew best experts were
not significantly better than
non-specialists the problem is most of
the events they have to predict are
one-offs they haven't had the experience
of going through these events or very
similar ones many times before
even presidential elections only happen
infrequently and each one in a slightly
different environment so we should be
wary of experts who don't have repeated
experience with feedback
the next requirement is a valid
environment one that contains
regularities that make it at least
somewhat predictable a gambler betting
at the roulette wheel for example may
have thousands of repeated experiences
with the same event and for each one
they get clear feedback in the form of
whether they win or lose but you would
rightfully not consider them an expert
because the environment is low validity
a roulette wheel is essentially random
so there are no regularities to be
learned
in 2006 legendary investor warren
buffett offered to bet a million dollars
that he could pick an investment that
would outperform wall street's best
hedge funds over a 10-year period hedge
funds are pools of money that are
actively managed by some of the
brightest and most experienced traders
on wall street they use advanced
techniques like short selling leverage
and derivatives in an attempt to provide
outsized returns and consequently they
charge significant fees
one person took buffett up on the bet
ted cites of protege partners for his
investment he selected five hedge funds
well actually five funds of hedge funds
so in total a collection of over 200
individual funds
warren buffett took a very different
approach he picked the most basic boring
investment imaginable a passive index
fund that just tracks the weighted value
of the 500 biggest public companies in
america the s p 500
they started the bet on january 1st 2008
and immediately things did not look good
for buffett it was the start of the
global financial crisis and the market
tanked but the hedge funds could change
their holdings and even profit from
market falls so they lost some value but
not as much as the market average
the hedge funds stayed ahead for the
next three years but by 2011 the s p 500
had pulled even and from then on it
wasn't even close the market average
surged leaving the hedge funds in the
dust after 10 years buffett's index fund
gained
125.8 percent to the hedge funds 36
percent
now the market performance was not
unusual over this time at eight and a
half percent annual growth it nearly
matches the stock market's long run
average so why did so many investment
professionals with years of industry
experience research at their fingertips
and big financial incentives to perform
failed to beat the market well because
stocks are a low validity environment
over the short term stock price
movements are almost entirely random
so the feedback although clear and
immediate doesn't actually reflect
anything about the quality of the
decision making
it's closer to a roulette wheel than to
chase
over a 10-year period around 80 percent
of all actively managed investment funds
fail to beat the market average and if
you look at longer time periods
underperformance rises to 90 percent and
before you say well that means 10 of
managers have actual skill consider that
just through random chance some people
would beat the market anyway portfolios
picked by cats or throwing darts have
been shown to do just that and in
addition to luck there are nefarious
practices from insider trading to pump
and dump schemes
now i don't mean to say there are no
expert investors i mean warren buffett
himself is a clear example but the vast
majority of stock pickers and active
investment managers do not demonstrate
expert performance because of the low
validity of their environment
brief side note if we know that stock
picking will usually yield worse results
over the long term and that what active
managers charge and fees is rarely
compensated for in improved performance
then why is so much money invested in
individual stocks mutual funds and hedge
funds
well let me answer that with a story
there was an experiment carried out with
rats and humans where there's a red
button and a green button that can each
light up
eighty percent of the time the green
button lights up and twenty percent of
the time the red button lights up but
randomly so you can never be sure which
button will light and the task for the
subject either rat or human is to guess
beforehand which button will light up by
pressing it for the rap if they guess
right they get a bit of food and if they
guess wrong a mild electric shock
the rat quickly learns to press only the
green button and accept the 80 win
percentage humans on the other hand
usually press the green button but once
in a while they try to predict when the
red light will go on and as a result
they guess right only 68 percent of the
time
we have a hard time accepting average
results and we see patterns everywhere
including in randomness so we try to
beat the average by predicting the
pattern but when there is no pattern
this is a terrible strategy
even when there are patterns you need
timely feedback in order to learn them
and youtube knows this which is why
within the first hour after posting a
video they tell you how its performance
compares to your last 10 videos there's
even confetti fireworks when the video
is number one i know it seems like a
silly thing but you have no idea how
powerful a reward this is and how much
youtuber effort is spent chasing this
supercharged dopamine hit
to understand the difference between
immediate and delayed feedback
psychologist daniel kahneman contrasts
the experiences of anesthesiologists and
radiologists anesthesiologists work
alongside the patient and get feedback
straight away is the patient unconscious
with stable vital signs with this
immediate feedback it's easier for them
to learn the regularities of their
environment radiologists on the other
hand don't get rapid feedback on their
diagnoses if they get it at all this
makes it much harder for them to improve
radiologists typically correctly
diagnose breast cancer from x-rays just
70 percent of the time
delayed feedback also seems to be a
problem for college admissions officers
and recruitment specialists
after admitting someone to college or
hiring someone at a big company you may
never or only much later find out how
they did this makes it harder to
recognize the patterns in ideal
candidates in one study richard melton
tried to predict the grades of freshmen
at the end of their first year of
college a set of 14 counselors
interviewed each student for 45 minutes
to an hour they also had access to high
school grades several aptitude tests and
a four-page personal statement for
comparison melton created an algorithm
that used as input only a fraction of
the information just high school grades
and one aptitude test nevertheless the
formula was more accurate than 11 of the
14 counselors
study was reported alongside over a
dozen similar results across a variety
of other domains from predicting who
would violate parole to who'd succeed in
pilot training if you've ever been
denied admission to an educational
institution or turned down for a job it
feels like an expert has considered your
potential and decided that you don't
have what it takes to succeed you know i
was rejected twice from film school and
twice from a drama program so it's
comforting to know that the gatekeepers
at these institutions aren't great
predictors of future success
so if you're in a valid environment and
you get repeated experience with the
same events with clear timely feedback
for each attempt will you definitely
become an expert in 10 000 hours or so
the answer unfortunately is no because
most of us want to be comfortable
for a lot of tasks in life we can become
competent in a fairly short period of
time take driving a car for example
initially it's pretty challenging it
takes up all of system 2 but after 50
hours or so it becomes automatic system
one takes over and you can do it without
much conscious thought after that more
time spent driving doesn't improve
performance if you wanted to keep
improving you would have to try driving
in challenging situations like new
terrain higher speeds or in difficult
weather now i have played guitar for 25
years but i'm not an expert because i
usually play the same songs it's easier
and more fun but in order to learn you
have to be practicing at the edge of
your ability pushing beyond your comfort
zone you have to use a lot of
concentration and methodically
repeatedly attempt things you aren't
good at you can
practice everything exactly as it is and
exactly as it's written
but at just such a speed that you have
to think about and know exactly where
you are and what your fingers are doing
and what it feels like this is known as
deliberate practice and in many areas
professionals don't engage in deliberate
practice so their performance doesn't
improve in fact sometimes it declines
if you're experiencing chest pain and
you walk into a hospital would you
rather the doctor is a recent graduate
or someone with 20 years experience
researchers have found that diagnostic
skills of medical students increase with
their time in medical school which makes
sense the more cases you've seen with
feedback the better you are at spotting
patterns but this only works up to a
point when it comes to rare diseases of
the heart or lungs doctors with 20 years
experience were actually worse at
diagnosing them than recent graduates
and that's because they haven't thought
about those rare diseases in a long time
so they're less able to recognize the
symptoms only after a refresher course
could the doctors accurately diagnose
these diseases
and you can see the same effect in chess
the best predictor of skill level is not
the number of games or tournaments
played but the number of hours dedicated
to serious solitary study players spend
thousands of hours alone learning chess
theory studying their own games and
those of others and they play through
compositions which are puzzles designed
to help you recognize tactical patterns
in chess as in other areas it can be
challenging to force yourself to
practice deliberately and this is why
coaches and teachers are so valuable
they can recognize your weaknesses and
assign tasks to address them to become
an expert you have to practice for
thousands of hours in the uncomfortable
zone attempting the things you can't do
quite yet
true expertise is amazing to watch to me
it looks like magic but it isn't at its
core expertise is recognition and
recognition comes from the incredible
amount of highly structured information
stored in long-term memory to build that
memory requires four things a valid
environment many repetitions timely
feedback and thousands of hours of
deliberate practice when those criteria
are met human performance is astonishing
and when it's not you get people we
think of as experts who actually aren't
if you want to become a stem expert you
have to actively interact with problems
that's what you can do with brilliant
the sponsor of this video check out this
course on computer science where you can
uncover the optimal strategy for finding
a key in a room and you quickly learn
how your own strategy can be replicated
in a neural network logic is another
great course that i find challenges me
mentally you go from thinking you
understand something to actually getting
it and if it feels difficult that's a
good thing it means you're getting
pushed outside your comfort zone this is
how brilliant facilitates deliberate
practice and if you ever get stuck a
helpful hint is always close at hand so
don't fall into the trap of just getting
comfortable and doing what you know how
to do build in the habit of being
uncomfortable and regularly learning
something new that is the way to
lifelong learning and growth so i invite
you to check out the courses over at
brilliant.org veritasium and i bet you
will find something there that you want
to learn plus if you click through right
now brilliant are offering 20 off an
annual premium subscription to the first
200 people to sign up so i want to thank
brilliant for supporting veritasium and
i want to thank you for watching